there's digital comic con going on right
now which is a fancy way of saying
trailers are dropping
time to talk i got to make this one fast
because sushima is not liberated yet i
got work to do so we have a trailer for
bill and ted face the music which is one
of those movies i'm
optimistic about yet cautiously
optimistic and with this trailer we see
a lot of what we already knew bill and
ted are like all right we gotta get this
song dude so they try to go to the
feature steal it from themselves we see
a little bit more of death it really
does touch on everything that bill and
ted
have done and been through to throw back
to their adventures even ted's dads in
the movie and he pretty much gives a lot
of i told you so speeches but what we
see more of for the first time
is bill and ted's daughters in the movie
and bill and ted's daughters actually do
what i
like about bill and ted's actual
adventure you know a thing
that made bill and ted click for me the
hook other than you know bill and ted
are
lovable idiots but really the hook for
me was the fact that you have
all these historical figures in one
movie
and then they go to the mall they start
raising havoc in the mall it's just fun
stuff
genghis khan messes up that sporting
goods store
i mean this this is classic so i'm glad
we see historical musical figures
getting picked out of history and
they're going to contribute to the end
product of the song that's gonna save
existence
however there is there's a thing in this
trailer
that makes me go that was that was done
on purpose
it's this phrase a song created by
preston logan
performed tonight we'll save reality as
we know it
the way it sounds it sounds like they
spliced out the first names it does
sound like there's a splice in there
between preston and logan
a song created by and if preston
making a leap call it hunch uh yeah
they're pressing in logan
but they're also prostin and logan so
you have the daughters writing the music
the dad's playing the music
family dynamics saves existence that
does sound like a winning dynamic though
you know it still makes bill and ted
relevant because they are the artists
who play the music but the word soul of
the music is created by their daughters
there is
something about that on paper that
really does
work for me they can really if they
stick the landing to this
it could be a really feel good movie
sounds great but this is hollywood so
if they can find a way to [ __ ] that up
they will i shouldn't say that
optimism folks optimism point is if you
have this really feel good coming
together of fathers and daughters
i mean i'll appreciate it but what i
don't want to happen in this movie is
walk out of the movie and then you start
connecting the dots when you get home
and i don't want to be like oh bill and
ted's story
went it led to absolutely nothing of
relevance and so
now they're irrelevant because that
basically means ted's dad was right
i mean if you look at it like you guys
are going to be losers forever
and bill and ted's excellent avenger was
like new dad
we're going to be somebody and we're
right yeah they're gonna save the future
but if they don't
then yeah ted's dad was right the whole
time so the trailer's entertaining my
guard's kind of up on this one because
of hollywood's track record of you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] up it's what they're good
at maybe bill and ted were meant to just
be a couple of
lovable 80s teen idiots in a time when
that was fine so that's me rambling
about a trailer for a couple minutes
gonna sum it up right here in four
syllables
i hope it's good we'll see how it goes
dude all right so the trailer to bill
and ted face the music have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more alright sushima
here i come
[Music]
you